vendre des informations world quand on
est policier bonsoir mesdames et
messieurs on revient sur cette grosse
histoire qui continue à ébranler le
monde policier et judiciaire avec de
nouveaux détails ce soir d'abord des
extraits de conversations entre l'ex
policier benoît roberge et le motard ni
charlebois que nous présente isabelle
richer aussi alain gravel nous donnera
le contenu du testament vidéo calais
cerné charlebois avant de se suicider il
dit des choses étonnantes comme par
exemple qu'il y aurait d'autres
policiers prêts à travailler avec les
motards isabelle de bord la police a
entre les mains
10 conversation entre les angels vallée
charlebois et l'ancien sergent détective
benoît roberge
certaines sont très courtes d'autres
durent près d'une quinzaine de minutes
dans l'une d'entre elle
on apprend comment charlebois s'y
prenaient pour payer les informations
hautement confidentielles que roberge
lui vendait un montant est mentionné
cent mille dollars
charlebois lui dit on va faire comme la
dernière fois mais ton auto sur le côté
et laisse les portières des barris on va
mettre l'argent sur la banquette arrière
tu leur as may sera plus tard le moteur
explique qu'il fournit 25 mille dollars
et salvatore cazzetta qu'il appelle la
barbe 75000 salvatore cazzetta est un
des membres les plus influents des hells
angels arrêtés dans l'opération sharqc
en 2009 mais libéré des accusations
depuis il a des contacts dans tous les
clans du crime organisé montréalais les
conversations révèlent que rené
charlebois ici pour obtenir des
informations sur l'endroit où se cachent
sylvain boulanger le témoin principal de
la couronne dans l'opération sharqc
charlebois promet beaucoup d'argent aux
policiers s'il trouve cette information
robert je réponds que c'est compliqué
difficile selon la preuve
rené charlebois se sert de roberge pour
en apprendre le plus possible sur les
sources
ceux qui collaborent avec les policiers
lors d'une conversation benoît roberge
est réticent à donner le nom d'une
source très bien que lundi
10 soit éliminé charlebois le rassure
inquiète toi pas on ne tuera pas on va
juste arrêter de travailler avec lui
benoît roberge donne finalement le nom
de la source
dans une autre conversation roberge
déclare qu'il est important qu'il ait un
petit magot pour se défendre
si jamais il se fait prendre il informe
aussi le moteur charlebois qu'il prend
sa retraite du spvm mais qu'il est
embauché par revenu québec où laura là
aussi accès à beaucoup d'informations
selon la preuve recueillie benoît
roberge aurait touché 500 mille dollars
au bas mot pour les informations refiler
aux motards des informations qui
auraient permis à plusieurs suspects
d'échapper à la police
et qui aurait fait avorter des enquêtes
en cours depuis des mois
isabel richer radio canada montréal
isabelle alain bonsoir isabelle on
comprend que l'argent vraiment à jouer
un rôle central
c'est une évidence dans cette affaire
lors tout cas pour monsieur robert
argent dont on n'a pas retrouvé la trace
patrice c'est pas faute de l'avoir
cherché mais sans succès pourtant comme
on l'entend du charlebois a redonné de
gros montants à roberge
on parle de 100 mille dollars et ont dit
on va faire comme la dernière fois donc
c'est permis de penser que benoît
roberge d'anciens policiers auraient
touché beaucoup d'argent
où est cet argent est possible de savoir
jusqu'à maintenant merci isabelle alain
on savait que rené charlebois